[Music]
I remember my dad played for NOS Ley and
isit as an amateur and NOS United had a
women's team and there was a lady called
Sylvia Gore who ended up becoming big on
the national scale so I've watched
women's I'm a football an I've watched
women's football grow I'm like brilliant
this is great so you did charity work
I didn't work in the women's industry P
I didn't work there but I watched it
grow women won't even watch women's
football and now and now I'm not allowed
to give an
opinion this way now now I'm not allowed
to give an opinion for fear of being
shouted down or some kind of right-wing
Looney or some misogynist I'm like no
I'm just saying he a [__] can we not say
you're a [__] loads of men are [__] as
well if you if you stop screaming at me
I I'll explain to you that I think
they're poor as well and they need work
um
but they just want to shout at you um
and that's the world that we live in
isn't it women love shouting at me you
must you must face an awful lot of um
blowback for The Stance you take because
I seen the looks they give um the the
the two ladies G gave you on the peers
and if Lu could
kill um I didn't actually mind the one
that I was in studio with she was at
least a little bit respectful like I
mean she was she seemed there to debate
but that other was just yelling yeah and
she she she done the way I didn't really
have to say anything cuz you know it was
self-evident um you know it was kind of
Point proven I think she she'd lost
anyone who who maybe would have um given
her a bit more time to to convince them
I think when she started shouting over
all of us not just me all of us I'm just
thankful I wasn't in the studio cuz I
think she might have cut me balls off if
she' got a chance I think if she'd got
hands on me you know she came with and
and and again it just shows you how you
know she was triggered clearly by what
it tweeted the words had triggered her
and she'd had enough of me and she wants
to give me a piece of her mind and um
fortunately you were there to save me
bacon pel thank you for that interally
grateful I was ex I was I was just happy
he asked my
opinion yeah I was I was um I was
wanting to hear a lot more from from
obviously the other people on the on the
show were obviously bian decided and I
liked when you just said to her this is
not a about you this is not about you
will you listen will you stop shouting
um but again you know when you get up
the next day and and you you analyze
what's gone before I think she'll be
disappointed with the version she gave
of hair truth and the fact that simps a
new word of land off you I didn't know
that word I love it you never heard the
word never heard it no I'm I'm 41 I'm
not of I'm not on YouTube I might have
been not that old it's like I know but
I'm not on I'm not down with act like
you're anxious honestly I'm not down
with the kids I I live in a football
bubble like I'm a football anarak who
lives in a football bubble and and tries
to interact with the world around them
and have you know done question time Etc
and all he do is beat you down with why
are you talking about that you and I'm
like well now I'm talking about
something I'm really credible in and now
you're not let me speak about that
either wa when can at all um and then
obviously you know for me I said to you
text you saying um took great
inspiration because it would have been
easy to keep your head down there and
you know you don't know me from Adam but
to see you stand up for what for what
you believed in and and and speak the
way you did to say for me it was
inspirational cuz I was having a wobble
in like do I really need this you know
I've got quite a nice life do I need
this aggro and then you hear people
speaking you know like yourselves and
other people out there and it inspires
you because you think if we don't say
anything here we're we're heading to the
mad house look at look at society as it
it's integrating around us I think maybe
maybe I I am a Bonafide expert in
women's football I'm going to apply
tomorrow well you've played of a season
a you you've got a season yeah I played
when I was a kid so I I know the corner
kicks and stuff okay so I can't see he's
like he's like we can work with this
you're overqualified based on what I'm
seeing on the TVs at the minute
definitely overqualified I I'll tell you
what I was a goalie and I was actually
pretty good but I couldn't punt okay so
that was the end of my career because
you couldn't kick you mean go kick yeah
well do we call it punt or may you call
it punt you just call it soccer as well
so pun for us is a goal kick or or or or
kicking oh okay so you just call it pun
don't you like the NFL the like when you
drop it and then you kick it across the
yeah I couldn't that one I couldn't do
it It's Tricky It's Tricky but um if you
want to be a good goalkeeper it's
something that you need in in in your I
know that's that's what he told me too
so I just kind of rode the bench I like
anything sport for me is is about
repetition Mo you know football is is
the same even though it doesn't think it
it benefits from repetitive action so
was only take a short that if you want
to get your gloves back on and go back
for for the season in the WSL next time
you're here we'll do a women's
goalkeeping sing off I mean you know
Nike didn't even produce um a lioness's
goalkeeper Ki for the women's oh I
should try to play no the the women Mar
ABS I think was the England goalkeeper
in the last tournament and they didn't
Nike obviously made the England kit
sold the women's Jersey The Outfield
Jersey but never made the women's
goalkeeping Jersey available for anybody
to buy yeah and it drove I think a lot
of traction in terms of people were
going bananas about it yeah and Nike
never folded and made the Jersy even
though I think over the course of the
tournament the the the initial um
dispute ended up making Mary almost the
started the tournament for England you
know she had a great tournaments as well
and raised their profile and yet you
couldn't buy a replica Jersey if you so
we're talking about equality diversity
and we're talking about you know
creating these opportunities for people
well how did imagine the England men's
team going the World Cup and you
couldn't buy the England men goalkeeper
shirt and the goalkeeper ends up being
the best player for them at the
tournament and they still don't sell the
Shar so why aren't they outside Nike in
in Oregon or outside Nike Nighttown in
Ox Street picking them and saying
where's this sh um I wish they'd put the
same energy into some of the causes as
doing into harassing people who
sometimes want to tell them the truth
yeah I think we should start a straight
white man scholarship oh God so you see
it's you you have a different take on
that as As Americans and you have got a
lot to um a lot to uh answer for in
terms of you know the the the the
problems with you know the repatriation
and all that that and your Society there
MH we have a problem with that cuz but
but it's not the Working Man we've never
owned yeah yeah slaves I've never you
know Americans didn't either what 100
years ago in England it used to say on
the shop Windows not even that 80 years
ago in England they used to say no Irish
no blacks no dogs I'm 50% Irish so we
were once yeah and and I'm working class
England we've had no advantages slavery
or well Irish were the first slaves in
America
sure yeah they don't count though cuz
they're white I guess again where did we
stop with this did we go back to the
Romans and say what what the Romans and
the Vikings have clearly um caused chaos
as well so for me we have to stop we
have to use the past as a reference and
understand it but I think we have to
stop looking into it and instead of
trying to redo wrongs of the past let's
fix the future where we can actually
affect it and find solutions for a
better more inclusive Society where we
all pull each other up stop attacking
each other and putting each other down
like that doesn't doesn't do anyone any
favors yeah so that's why I was
delighted to meet you this week I've
learned Lots meeting you obviously
incredible setup and how advanced you
are and how far into the future um you
know your that's all blessing I got to
say listen team team workor Makes the
Dream Work doesn't it clearly you've got
a fantastic team around you which is
what everybody needs and you are moving
into a direction where I think I've got
a nine-year-old daughter Peter and I'm
like I I'm I do me boxing cuz my wife
watches she's got no interest in sport
me misses and she's you know the
Kardashians and stuff like that me
little girl is a proper little girl like
she's got no interest in football where
me boys are football D football mad and
I want her to have aspiring Role Models
whichever way she chooses in music in
sports and Kardashians and influences
for me really wor me you know CU they're
encouraging plastic surgery and you're
not good enough and you don't look good
enough and you're not slim enough and
you haven't got the right product and
know and I think that is a dangerous
message to to send to Young fertile
female Minds yeah and honestly I said to
you when when I heard your voice I'm
like oh my God there is some women out
here who are who are trying to give a
different message you know don't just
use your sexuality to get ahead what's
very confusing too as a young chick like
especially with the stuff they're P I
can't think of one good female role
model in media can't I maybe I like uh
Candace Owens maybe I do like her but C
I can think of a couple conservatives
that are okay but overall like half of
them just they just get naked see your
sport kind of American sport seems a lot
further down the track in terms of I
even think the way you educate you know
when I when I think about your punditry
and your ccoms the level of training
they do before they usually get on the
big NBCS or is NBC that your big or the
when I watch the NFL and I see Troy aan
ESP they're always slick and really come
on they don't leay on the job if you go
back and watch ours like Gary Neville's
face appearance on Monday Night Football
it's a car crash like he the way dressed
first first and foremost never mind what
actually came out of his mouth
afterwards which was just nonsense to be
fair to G's got better since and he's SE
he's seen him and Jamie carer seen as
some of the better ones out there and
I'm like I don't think they are for
that's a conversation for another day
but again they shouldn't be laying on
the job in the job they should be taken
away a bit of time out go and get the
professional training and come back and
be really good that's all I'm saying in
in our industry male or female put the
best person in front of the camera CU if
you're paying £150 a month for your Sky
TV Broadband package and you want the
best most
educated people on the TV so I can learn
or your kids can learn about whatever
sport it is you're watching and then all
of a sudden these token people are on
there MH talking factually incorrect
things with the wrong tone and and they
make you mute the TV and and you're
disengaged and if we keep doing that we
keep disengaging our audience it's going
to damage our product financially which
is going to damage the industry and and
the opportunities for everybody who
comes after I'm okay I make gravy when
the gravy train was rolling I'm also not
beholden to anybody at the minute so for
me I'm like somebody's got to say
something I wish it wasn't me really I
do probably you're the same you wish
somebody else like when I see you I'm
like I'm I'm made up somebody else is
taking his fight on because it can be um
it can be tough sometimes cuz none of us
wants to upset people I don't want to
upset anybody I want to try to find a
better way of working in the future but
also if you're not going to listen to me
and I'm I have the ability to offend you
because I I don't I don't believe that
maybe you'll answer me differently I
don't believe you can be offended by
somebody else no I agree it's a choice I
believe you choose to so like words if
you if you came to me and said you fat
bastard it would hate me a little bit at
this moment cuz I'm out of shape well
but when I'm playing in the Premier
League and I've got a six I'd be like
what you on about she she's a bit mad so
so at a level to get offended by
something I mean you can imagine and
you're probably one of the few people I
can talk about like this you can imagine
whenever I say anything or do anything
you get a polarizing opinion online some
people say some really nice things some
people play say incredibly crazy things
um and as you navigate that you know
maybe they 20 some 401 now two decades
into getting abused for you know people
who don't know me you build up this kind
of resilience towards it then you
realize even when it does offend you you
sit and go it's actually only words I
have had to
allow those words in to allow it to
affect my emotional state and I could
have just blocked that out almost like
somebody knocks on me door Steve black
used to always say to me Joe about
negative thoughts imagine somebody
knocking on your door with muddy boots
on and you've just had a nice cream
carpet laid you'd open the door and
you'd go you're not coming in cuz if you
come in you're going to cause chaos so
you're going to stand outside or take
your wellingtons off before you're
allowed in but when we allow negative
thoughts in or negative words in it's
exactly the same you're basically
allowing somebody to ruin your nice
lovely cream carpet with Muddy Wellies
well and that's why I don't understand
why men can't make General statements
about women without women taking it
personal women always take it personal
that's why on the show when she was
saying oh I had this amazing career I
was like no one no one's talking about
you if it doesn't apply Let it Fly
that's what I was talk if it yeah but if
it doesn't apply to you then why are you
offended so so I'm kind of widger on
that in terms of
like why did you feel the need to she
was saying she's been watching football
since before I was born so and again
people who make that argument I turned
up at nine and I left at nine that's
great but what happens if I turn up at
nine I leave at 10 and I've done [__]
more than you're in that hour than what
you've done in the [__] 12 hours
surely it's about quality not quantity
um you know some of the best people in
the world world are short on time and
they turn up for 15 minutes they
sprinkle a magic and they're gone some
some other people turn up and they spend
15 hours they do nothing yeah you know
and and
everyone for me is is on a sliding scale
of credibility so if I meet you and
you're a former
International player who's won all these
trophies you probably start on my scale
of credibility near a 100 and then every
time you open your mouth and every time
you put a training session on that that
if it's poor it'll slide towards zero
similarly if I don't know you and you're
a female or you're a a male who hasn't
played men's footy you'd maybe start
based on my first interaction with you
near a zero you know based on your
personality I'd go okay he's a nice
person so we give him a 20% or what
whatever you know no one would start on
zero unless I disliked you before I
walked in but most had start on about 20
and then i' converse with you over the
period you'd put a session on you'd
you'd offer me a few of your opinions
and and then if they were good opinions
that would slide towards the 100 yeah
and you might have have after two years
the international player who's played at
the highest level and won everything
down a 40 because he talks nonsense all
the time and acts like a kned all the
time and you might have the person who
hasn't done any football up near 100 at
80 Who You'd listen to and you go what
else do you know what else can you teach
me about this and what's wrong with
saying people should earn the right to
be in the job or be in the building like
why if you don't want to do the work and
you're not good enough you want truth
hurts and a lot of women know that
they're given jobs because they're women
and not because they're the most
qualified they wouldn't be offended if
it wasn't true okay and and in in the
women's industry like in in terms of
working you know American sport I would
imagine um is a lot more advanced in
this uh than know in terms of I met a a
lady from well I I don't see it just Meg
papovich or something like that I went
to leaders in sport there was a lady
spoke Meg papovich who's maybe Toronto
Maple Leaves or something and she was
really really impressive and I thought
I'd follow I'd listen to you well I
don't even think it's just in sports I
see it in like Corporate America too
where they they just give women in
general like hand even the whole
education system is based on how women
learn not men so it's not like favored
towards men women receive preferential
treatment from like a super young age
okay so like even um like for example
like men are a lot more logical and so
they like like so when you make like
attendance grades like that favors women
because women like would go more just to
go rather than to like like men will go
if they find it beneficial but a women
like won't I that makes sense you see I
see with my little girl I me my Elder
son's 11 mhm and my little daughter's
nine Peter and in schooling terms she
just get it way more than him I think
little boys want to be out running
around and quite wild and I think young
girls are a lot more mature than young
boys and and and get the Lear in the 70s
they switched it or 607s so it used to
just be that like it would just be like
a standardized test so you would take
the test and however you scored that was
like how you would do but then they
added things like homework they added
things like atten to add into your grade
and that like feminizes a it a little
bit and it favors women because those
are things that women tend to so did
teachers are 85% women too so it starts
from like a super even if you look at
like Corporate America like Twitter um
like there's a lot of women that have
useless jobs like in Corporate America
that they're just given because they
have a diversity quot and you see that
because whenever there's layoffs and
like they basically have to start making
money the most useless people go look at
the before and after picture of
Twitter like all the women are
gone and I'm this this is not to say I
hate that I always have to say this
there were so super smart capable women
you meet a lot of them in sports
actually because Sports is like you know
outside of commentator but like actually
playing like one of theocracy you're
based on results yeah exactly and it's
one of the few places that I think women
get that so I find it a lot but um so
that's why when I came on the show with
you I was like I know exactly what's
going on cuz I I see it everywhere I see
so where we're heading here is I a
disgruntled poor male footballer decides
I can be myarm Lon Messi esque women
footballer and and decid to take
advantage of that which is only a matter
of the time if they keep pushing pushing
the other one is if we're truly about
diversity and equality and all that how
long is it before we say okay we're
going to have 11 men and one woman on
every team or we're going to have 11 men
and two women on every team because we
need to get the women in the you know we
need to show these Pathways every male
team should have one at least one woman
in the team like it can really become
this pervers if if we're not careful on
it yeah well and it's
not I I just don't think we should even
as women really aspire to be in the
men's game I just I think it's dangerous
for us um I I've played with guys and if
there's a certain level like for
basketball because I played basketball
too um if they are trained past like two
years of high school I I just won't do
it cuz I don't want to get hurt so I was
I was shocked when I face met you today
about like obviously I expect you to be
quite small and petite when a seen you
on the TV and I turned up and and I
could see how you've been a good athlete
in terms of I think
you're bigger than average for a girl oh
yeah I'm yeah so you're about 510 looks
I'm 6 foot you're six foot so you're
actually bigger than me right I'm 5'11
on a good day and I'm shrinking now with
be really poor posture um so you're
actually bigger than me right
mhm I couldn't outrun you
though again even though you're you're
you you're taller than me yeah people
should say well they should be able to
compete no but obviously the velocity
and the physicality in there is is
incredible in in terms of and until
you've experienced that in terms of
competition I think it's really really
difficult to say I would have done this
yeah I would have done that I mean if
you get there's a GoPro camera on a
player I think it's a man a man playing
in a game might be Neymar and the way
he's moving on the GoPro when he's
flicking it over other men who are not
as far away in terms of physical output
is what the top woman player would be is
scary you know and then I think if we
get that I mean I think it was Gavin
peacock the ex- footballer who was
supporting some of the things we'd
agreed on on on um what we've spoken
about on P's show and a guy or guy or a
guy have to say somebody underneath a
tweeted um the US I think it was the
men's under 16 collegia um 100 meter 200
met all every Olympic event and the
women's Olympic scores and overlap them
men versus women and the men under 16
boys pretty much cleared the top five
positions in every category so they're
the fastest women and the most athletic
women on the planet because they're at
the Olympics winning medals and they're
being beaten
on explosive physical um from 100 met to
5,000 meter from Javelin long long junk
Shut by teenage boys you know boys who
aren't even at the end of their puberty
testosterone stage and I mean obviously
they're going to win but again and it
was the same thing this is the thing
with rapper now you know obviously again
we can have that discussion for another
day and equal pay which I'm for if
you're good enough and you're a woman
you you should be able to get the same
earn more money than man if you're
better suited for the job of course you
should there should be no cap on what
you're capable of of of doing or earning
but also if you want to be itting on
900,000 a week like aing Garland
unfortunately you've got to score them
goals in the Premier League the WSL even
after the lionesses in a ticket boom and
is not going to generate them figures on
advertising on ticket sales on
merchandise on Global TV revenue and you
don't ever see men complaining about the
places that women have it like no guy
can take off his clothes and make
millions of dollars on off can't they
I'm new to all this this YouTube and
every day yeah they probably pay me
millions of pounds to put me clothes
back on so maybe that's a revenue stream
um body like a badly packed Rook sack at
at the but there are 18yearold like
there's an 18-year-old that made $50
million by doing that $50 million this
is the thing isn't it with with equal
pay and and again you know we have to
have a conversation about it I think I
think men have suppressed women for
probably 1,800 years of the 2,000 years
of recorded history if not more you know
the the suffet I I don't see anybody
throwing themselves in front of the
king's horse at Ascot anymore which is
what Emily panc did for the suffragettes
I'm pretty sure she didn't want this
this oh no they did they were evil you
you don't actually know you have you
read the history of them no I just knew
they were like militant women's group
who were who were desperate for women's
jobs no they they were communists like
they it's so funny they're terrorists
they like they organized like terrorist
attacks but they they they parade them
as hero it's the same way they rewrite
like the history of slavery like they
totally rewrite it they rewrite the
history of the suffragettes and they
basically say that like basically like
they their early writings they're known
as spinsters okay and married women
didn't want the right to vote what's a
spinster is a Spiner like old yeah not
get married and so like there's posters
back then like basically there were more
women that didn't want to vote than did
okay and because the reason they said
and this is why this is why it sounds
radical when I say this but um Back Then
basically they said if you let women
vote this is going to be the breakdown
of the family what happened you're going
to see tax is getting raised what
happened you're going to see um Bas
you're basically going to see the
destruction of society that's what women
that were married to their husband said
and they said these are spinster women
don't listen to them and yeah I don't
sounds familiar that doesn't it there
like that's what I'm saying like the
suff so I always seen kind of tianan
square and the the stand the man who
stands in front of the tank I didn't see
it I was too young to see it live but I
remember it like a shocking image of it
I'd seen in certain parts of Asia people
self- imilate you know people take
themselves and just set themselves on
fire and obviously the big thing that
you know I was into horse racing I've
been involved in owning and breeding
race horses don't anymore but did in in
in another life earlier on to me uh
existence and for for a woman for the
the Derby in England is Super Bowl of
horse racing and and obviously for a for
a woman to run on the track and throw
herself in front of the horse and the
horse kill her it was the king's horse
who killed her for me it's like okay wow
firstly wow are you prepare if you're
prepared to take that stance we need to
figure out how we've not how not Sol the
issue before that mentally but it was a
bigger movement behind it it wasn't just
Emily was it maybe you know I don't know
as much about what was she why did she
throw herself in front of the horse
because it was the king's horse it was
the king's horse on the biggest day and
and it was hundreds of thousands in the
crowd and she picked the way out it's
it's it's Harin footage actually when
you see it and she picks her way through
and basically makes a it's incredible if
she's actually targeted the king's horse
cuz she's known this is going to be a
huge Collision
well it goes over it and kills her yeah
well see my thing with women voting is I
just don't believe that you should get
the freedom to vote with without the
responsibility that comes with it I
think you should be a net taxpayer I
think you should be doing the dangerous
hard jobs that men do in society but
there's some men who you go surely he
should not be allowed to vote I agree
with you I think a lot of men shouldn't
vote too we're getting into kind of
Chinese kind of when we decide who can
and who can't vote it's dangerous
territory history most people didn't
vote in the US like it wasn't it was
only like landowning males that could
vote but imagine imagine you like just
look at your last election in the states
and obviously the big um the big stolen
election uh conspiracy or whatever it
was I don't know enough about it so but
imagine selected people were allowed to
vote and then you had a result that
didn't go for them if only men voted in
the last hundred years it would have
gone conservative every time and I
thought Hillary Clinton was going to get
in I thought there's no way women are
too easily manipulate like most
propaganda techniques work on women
that's why they Market to us we make 80%
of consumer buying decisions so what
they realized was if they gave women the
right to vote they can manipulate us and
win elections so that's why you'll see
like a 12-year-old that can't get an
abortion right before election season
every time there's always some sob story
right before elections even the BLM
stuff that was run by women all of that
all of those in in America as say it
massively Alters our society because the
world's become very small now very
Global you know we we don't really watch
British TV anymore you you watch
whatever TV you want from all around the
globe you know most of that influen is
certainly when it comes to like TV shows
and news now is is in the states yeah so
we I I'm always watching kind of America
to see what's happening in America
thinking this is going to come it'll
come here this is coming our way some
some form of fashion now there there's
things obviously that you have problems
with that we don't in fact the fact that
people are walking around with like
automatic rifles and guns everywhere I
can't imagine our country if you had
that cuz I you'd have like 15,000 deaths
a day if you got the angry angry British
motorist out and about um you know car
parking spaces to be just uh there just
be corpses everywhere over like at Asda
on tesos um especially if you could buy
like an assault rifle in as on tesos and
ammunition um but again you know your
Society is evolved a completely
different way from ours like you have
actually you Saed a native population
and you what you've taken a native
population off its own land with the
Indians not really see that that's a
problem it's all
propaganda like most Native Americans
died from disease like
98% of them yeah but that was brought by
the settlers oh yeah I mean I'm not
saying it was like but but they would
all fight with each other any anyway
that was just like the way of the world
then but again the way you're so so the
people I believe from Europe that came
to America to for the new world yeah had
all these great ideas about how the
feudal system in Europe wasn't working
how the monarchies in Europe Wars so
they turned up on the Mayflower and
thought right we're going to settle East
Coast here and we're going to run this
perfect society and then you know if if
you read about those early excusions you
know the the natives were raiding there
so obviously they they got off on the
wrong foot and straight away um and then
when you watch how that Society grows
and grows and grows and then spreads
right across the
continent it's just such you basically
Europe yeah in a hundred years you You'
you know we've got Italy to Spain to
Portugal to France to Germany to Austria
to Yugoslavia yeah we've got such
different beliefs and backgrounds and
and and all of a sudden America America
is the same size if not bigger with with
as many people as Europe yeah and
they're all trying to fit into the same
belief system with the same rules and
the same and it must be really really
difficult you know your Constitution and
the found of fathers M all male all the
certain demographic yeah lots of slave
owners yeah um and we haven't had that
all our landed aristocracy that's why I
speak here about the class system in our
country MH you know the king and and and
all ones with double battle names have
um made money in in the you know the
colonies you know the expansion of our
Commonwealth and and the
Empire working half
Irish sons of miners oh I see sons of
dockyard workers son Sons of butchers we
we haven't had we haven't had any
benefit of they group you guys into that
yeah we've we've always had to struggle
you know if you read George Orwell's
road to wig and Pier about the
conditions for the working class and the
the north of England in
1936 we've got 10 11 people sleeping in
in one room no heating outside toilets
that are shared by the
community Life's a lot better than 2023
in less than a 100 years you know Life's
a lot better I think the average miners
yearly salary was
like15 that was before he had to pay for
his lamp and his all the other bits that
go with it and these football teams all
not all most were built by the support
of these working class communities and
the men that were good enough from those
communities not to have to go work down
of mind but you know your bill shankley
your jock steens your samat Busby the
iconic you watch the movie The Three
Kings about the best football managers
so that's Celtic Glasgow Celtic
Manchester United and obviously
Liverpool the the Giants that of the
game that they wear whose whose
shoulders we all stand upon were all
workingclass men from within miles of of
of a pit in Scotland MH where's where's
the equity of the men who've done all
the work over hundreds of years why why
is our equity and the fact that we've
put our bodies on the
line um sold down the river to to to fit
these equality and diversity quots I'm
all for it but we've got to have skin in
the game you've got to have equity in
the game if you've built the industry
you've built the football club with your
performance right you have a right to
have benefit of that yeah when your body
may be because of the impact and the
injury you've you've you've you've done
getting there no longer work for you as
well as it could
and with the greatest respect we've got
women footballers coming out of the
women's game who've had very who've got
no equity in our game who haven't done
who haven't done any of the Spade work
who haven't done any of the hard yards
and are expect an all the reward and I
think that's wrong I just think that's
the wrong message to send what blessing
we're recording right okay I just want
to make sure um so what made you want to
initially speak out about it I didn't so
I I've been in as a manager for five
years so I stopped playing after I
retired at 35 because I got banned for
gambling to the court and all the
accounts I had where I used to do footy
coupons and the fa through the Boo at me
you got banned for gambling so I used
used to be able to gamble on football so
I grew up gambling on football okay so
I'd go to bet shot with my Grandad at
like 13 or 14 I'd put two or three
horses on i' put a football coupon
football coupon would be you know
whatever result you felt were going that
weekend it might be you know fancy this
team to be that team that and you might
have three teams in it you might have
five teams in it who knows but you might
say they'll beat them one nil and
Cristiano Ronaldo will Score first goal
you know and if you if if they won one
nil and Ronaldo scored first goal you
might get like 16 to one odds okay um
your CL is slightly different because
you of band Sports gambling sports
betting in America haven't you it's
coming back a little bit oh I don't I
don't I don't gam you don't have like B
like us where like our our culture's
based on gambling as well P so I used to
go with me Granddad and I'd to have a
horse racing coupon and a footy coupon
couple of pound that was your weekend
and then you watch the results come in
and win or lose on you know you youd cry
in your in your in your roast dinner on
a Sunday or you pick up your winnings on
a Sunday whichever way it went and then
I started playing football but I was a
gambler before I was a footballer so I
had my own online gambling account then
I won't name the the booth maker but I
had my own online gambling account and
then I became a footballer and then once
I was 24
for um the Premier League decided to to
tighten up the the betting like Lads we
could bet on games that didn't involve
us they said okay so we couldn't bet on
any games we played in but we could bet
on other games then after the year they
tighten that up and said right you can't
bet on in any competition you're playing
in you can bet on like the Spanish
league if you don't play in the Spanish
league if you play in the English league
but you can't bet on the European Cup if
your team's in the European Cup then it
just it got Tighter and Tighter and
Tighter and the reason it got Tighter
and Tighter and Tighter is to protect
the betting Market in the Far East
because it's such a ridiculous revenue
for them I mean more money has bet on
the race in a CH in Hong Kong in one in
three days than is in the whole of
Britain on every single sport across the
sport and Cal calendar so they want to
capitalize on the re Vue of this far
east Pon market so to do that they have
to protect it almost Draconian rules to
come down on anybody so that nobody in
the Far East thinks that our products
tainted so so what were you betting so I
was betting on all sports right across
it including football so I'd L come home
from training sling the TV on and if if
did you know or like what so so I knew I
was breaking the rules eventually but
when we when aair started they there was
there wasn't the rules and then the
rules got tightened I was kind of like
we're not cheating we're no one's trying
to fix games yet we're having a you're
trying to predict Sport and outcomes
based on the knowledge you've got you
know they banned you from the whole
league so what happened I went to sign
for uh Glasgow ra Rangers up in Scotland
and um
anyway one of the betting accounts I had
was with a group called Paddy Power who
are based in Ireland who looks like you
know Ireland's a republic of Ireland's a
huge Celtic Northern Island a bit more
glasg Rangers it's separated on a
religious divide we won't get into that
there a conversation for another day and
when I was at Rangers bear in mind i'
had 12 years betting 13 years betting on
these same accounts in England no one
had ever so I thought well I'm not doing
any wrong I'm just having a 40 coupon oh
clearly no one's bothered by it they're
looking for match fixers or people who
are making money cheating yeah you know
fixing games or or throwing games or
betting on cards or spot betting which
is what where the major money is is they
were playing the Rangers Glasgow Derby
and then they have a bet after that on
Celtic next game against Barcelona MH
and it was correct and I had only say
2,000 nothing to do with me I went
playing in the competition and I this
somebody at pad power picked up on that
give it to the Scottish fa Scottish fa
then give it to the fa the fa then
looked historically into the BET of D
them I give them all my accounts and
said look this is what I've bet on I'm
being transparent these are all my
accounts I've been betting on fo footb I
shouldn't have been bet on football but
I'm a football addict I'm a football fan
like I want to try and predict football
it's the industry I know and wa so they
kicked you out for that so they banned
me for 18 months and at the time they
had a 12 million pound sponsor on the
front of the England shet with lad
Brooks the gambling partner so I'm like
this is hypocrisy so I wrote a letter
about it and and event and and they
eventually reduced me ban on appeal to
nine months because they'd gone too far
I believe it was it was too harsh and
they had to drop a 12 million sponsor so
I think they would deally unhappy with
that and since then you know amongst
other things I think you know I've just
said okay well so so when when you
decided to be Jesse James you know and I
didn't want to be but they've made me it
and I'm like okay I'm okay with this I'm
okay so what made you want to speak out
about women commentators well was there
like a coaching managing was there like
a clip that said who said you are no
there there's about 50 Clips so and
again there's some males who send it
over the edge as well so listen this is
not just no but we could start
the yeah I don't and I don't want to
pick any of them out cu I think it's
unfair I think I can speak about the
ones who were good I don't mind doing
that no I'm just wondering like was
there a moment that like made you want
to tweet that yeah so you just tell me
what happened you have to say who it was
so I'm watching um I'm watching football
as a manager in the last few years I've
been managing for five years two and a
half years six weeks off two and a half
years and you only watch your team and
your league cuz that's where you need to
get results to stay your job you don't
really you know you're watching other
teams and other games but you're not
really focusing on it because you're so
busy with your own job cuz it's an all
consuming
job and then I've come out of work and
obviously I speak to men so I speak to
men a lot about football because
everyone knows I've played and wants to
tell me their opinion and what they
think and and and I'm happy to do that
cuz I'm a football fan I love conversing
and engaging with people even if I
disagree them think they're mad you know
talking about flat air for no gravity
I'm like okay this is interesting let's
let whatever it is but anyway this way
it goes you know so you're having these
football conversations and you can pick
up men are going you know and they're
talking about you know tell got and
you're like so you can feel right you
know I filtered a lot of male
frustration you know the gloves are off
you know they tell me exactly what
they're thinking there's no political
correctness about it you know and I play
golf and I'm in a very male industry and
I'm a very um okay I don't spend a lot
of time in like women hair salons or
anything like that I spend me a lot of
time around men because the Sports and
the things I'm interested in that's
where they compete or that's that's you
know that's where you are um so I'm
watching the game um as a fan now
because I've been sacked from Bristol
Rovers so I'm not I'm now back not in
work mode what's happening with my team
my league I'm now back in fan mode okay
let's watch this even though I've got
all these opinions in my mind that
people have told me I'm like okay let's
watch this and I watch
and I'm
like you know credibility scale every
I'm going okay I'm trying to be
impartial even though I'm I'm I'm
tainted in terms of the opinion I've had
I'm trying to be impartial and every
single one I see on the
TV almost with exception chips away at
Women's credibility in the game chips
away chips away chips away chips away
and then I was watching on an illegal
stream on the internet um Liverpool game
and I don't really follow Liverpool I'm
an evertonian and I thought I'll watch
this game I'm away playing
golf and i' had a backlog of women talk
and so so the volcano is is slowly
filling with the mag the Magna is
filling the
chamber and the Liverpool Fulham game
where where the lady comms and cooms
described a technical action that was
just wrong and it was wasn't corrected
not that they got it wrong we all make
mistakes but the fact that nobody went
in and corrected it and said and and
Casas was like never done that and he's
11 and I was like no he didn't that was
a side for finish and he'd recognized at
11 without playing a game that that the
the shot with the laces wasn't the shot
with the laces and he could have his own
little but I left it I know we saying
that but I left it then p p I stayed
away from it cuz I thought that's just
wrong stayed away from it that was on
the satday and was this on like a major
Network
um I'm not sure actually cuz it was was
a it was an illegal stream I'm not sure
whether it was pulled to that stream
okay because the game wasn't on live and
obviously if you go on the internet now
you can search around and find games
live um and if you use um um what's it
call you block the server tell server or
somewhere else bpn um then you can
obviously tune into content that you're
not meant to be able to get so then on
the Sunday I watched the games again cuz
I thought that can't be right that that
was on a foreign Channel wasn't on ours
and obviously on the Sunday more of it
comes out yeah Monday I'm thinking okay
Monday we got away with it Monday Night
Football was they kept it uh
female free on the Monday Night Football
Monday Night Football for us in England
is is is almost like it's it's a real
educational thing they've done correctly
and if you remember sky at the start of
the Season put a decorated women's
player on there in in Karen carneo and I
think Karen's lovely person and was
obviously a good footballer and they put
Karen with Gary Neville and Cara who
were quite sto in there to take on
football and it was really really
awkward it it actually tainted the show
massively and credit to Sky I think they
recognized and had enough feedback she's
not been in that position since and I
don't think it's fair on Karen to put
there because she had to get her air
time and every time she spoke she lost
credibility MH and it was unfair because
she was in a position where she was
underqualified same way I be talking
about the Formula 1 I'm just going to
get of disdain because I don't know what
I'm on about even though I've driven a
car even though I've gone 100 miles 80
70 M an hour tops um um officially you
know yeah officially you know I can't I
can't understand what it's like to go
around a corner of a Formula 1 car cuz
I've never driven one and that's not to
say I won't ever be able to understand
it if I spend 20 years in the industry
and I work hard and I go in the pit line
and I ask the pant questions that
doesn't mean I can't get a great level
of understanding mhm but it just means
until I've got done the work I'm I'm
going to be inferior and and I if I put
myself in that position I'm going to my
self Ware is going to be down CU people
are going to Tweet me and say what the
[__] was you on about the Formula One
yeah and it's unfair to the person CU
they they think they deserve something
they don't yeah and then they can't
succeed because they're not qualified so
standards are lowered to fill quoters so
again again on the way let me finish so
Wednesday for me Tuesday and Wednesday
I've I've I've started playing snooker
so really tricky game right snooker I've
started playing snooker in a league an
amateur League purely for competition
cuz I love competition I want to be
competing and I can't compete on a
football pitch anymore on the male side
MH watch this space you know but like I
can't compete on the male side but I
love competition I love competing that's
why I love betting because me and you
want to predict the outcome yeah we have
a pound on it me and Cass has play FIFA
we have a pound on it or a cup of tea on
it
it means something if we don't play for
anything meaningless so you know even if
it's you going to make your bed if you
lose or I'll buy you a football kid
whatever it is for me that competitive
comp competition that Competitive Edge
is is Sport and is life pretty much so I
sat on the volcano I could feel it
bubbling and I I feel I'm going to say
something I was like no wait till the
wait till wait till the podcast launch I
said to Josh and Noah once what this is
the topic I know there's a scab that I
can feel if we pick it off a lot of
people are going to come forward and say
you know what I feel the same way yeah
so I could feel that undercurrent you
know you you you've also got to say the
right thing at the right time to to the
right people to me progress so I could
kind of feel it that although I was
wanting to keep that until after they
got Christmas and New Year out the way
had a nice holiday and then podcast
launch in the second half of uh January
and and then we'd get this traction so
playing snooker Wednesday with the with
the lads and i' had a couple of PS at
the snooker and we're playing and it
came up in top of again because the
Champions League was going around and
they were on pontificating again we're
listening to it as we're playing snook
like what and I'd had four points and it
taken off the sensible catch I usually
have on Twitter and it tweeted and it's
made that that initial tweet is what got
to foro and I think what was it 10
million impressions 10 million
impressions something like that yeah um
so clearly I've touched on a topic that
it's not just me and then the feedback
I've had honestly it's been incredible
terms of positive there obviously been
some negative not just male lots of
stone football fans who who who were
ladies who were like we completely agree
with you yeah you
know they they are having their love for
the for the for the game tainted by the
same problems we are it's not get women
out of football absolutely not we want
to I'm I come from a matriarchal family
my grandmother Julia Barton is the
greatest influence on my life my wife is
the second greatest influence on on my
life and then my daughter so I want to
see them empowered everywhere but I
don't want them losing credibility and
and getting belittled in the workplace
because people have shown them into a
position they shouldn't be in I want
them to be there on Merit standing the
ground fighting for everything they
believe in with a real confidence
knowing that they deserve to be in that
position they deserve to be in that room
and it is that so wrong to say that is
that the wrong message to send like yeah
you know it's tough so what was what was
the blowback like when when did Pierce
reach out so what I'd obviously tweeted
and then went to bed you know and then
got up the next day and I was did you
see the picture to put a PE the why
Always me once it was batelli the what
say that again so I I photoshopped a
picture of Manchester City player
batelli famously pulled his jzz up why
Always me so I super imposed
a picture of me that I had in my photo
real selfie like messing around I wasn't
drunk but I was pulling a stupid face so
I superimposed almost like my drunk face
on one and then the superimposed I did a
shoot for I think GQ and and they put a
halo over my head obviously because I'm
such a well behaved man in society and
I'm known in my industry for being
impeccably behaved so they put a halo
over my head when it was when I was
younger so I put why Always me with my
drunken head
on the angel invasion of me there and
then PE standing at the side cuz I was
like this [__] shouldn't have said
that out loud for another month but he
said it and now the angel has got to go
on the TV and try and say I actually
didn't mean that this is what I meant
and face obviously um the the the people
who didn't agree with with what it said
um so you know if he had me time again
would have do the same thing again
absolutely because I think it's
something that needed to be saying and
and obviously in the in the proce to
that get to meet you and see what
wonderful way you're doing learning all
the time learning about the suffrage yet
like I'm all I want to do is Lear and if
mean you were talking and somebody
listens to it and learns and becomes
better educated to make better
decisions why why why should we not why
should we not take on difficult and
that's why I don't understand why we
can't as women have the conversation
that like do we deserve the positions
we're in and there are some women that
I'm sure are and that are super qualif
but it's like why can't we have that
conversation and not get offended but
also there's there's lots of things that
are closed off to all of us this this
chair squeaking behind picks up on the
mic um I can't be king of England you
can't be Queen of England because you're
not born and don't have the BL blood L I
was really hoping there's a lots of
things also you can't do because of your
be like there's yeah you know there
there's certain positions that are
protect like there's certain positions
in our military that you cannot get
because you're not born to the right
family now is that right
I don't know but we haven't got equality
and and diversity everywhere you know so
we've got it in certain places where we
focus attention but haven't got other
places like sky for instance who have
gone very woke in the TV have gone very
woke in front of the camera go and look
at the executive producers and the
people who have earned lots of money
they're all white oh yeah so it's okay
diversifying the camera but they never
they never talk about it where women
benefit either so like you'll never hear
them say oh the the the the worker needs
the male sex worker needs just as much
money as the women you'll never you'll
never hear it you know equal rights
equal pay on all that yeah but I don't
see them banging on saying why can't we
be a bin man why can't we why can't we
wake down the sewers like why can't we
have them job why can't we be on the
building side doing them our jobs it's
always why can't it be Chief I asked one
of my first time on Pierce that's what I
asked her CU I was on with a feminist
and she was like crying about the pay
Gap and so I just said okay be equal you
know there's a building being built next
door out here go go work on it but
surely like we we know these like so
Taylor Swift and Beyonce in as as much
if not more than any Elite level
billionaire but why because they've
built the platform they sell the
merchandise they sell the records They
good they're the best at what they do
yeah not not not the other way around
where you haven't done those hard yards
you haven't built that audience so
YouTube for me like yourself MH you're a
prime example of there somebody who's
gone right okay I'm going to take this
on and this is the space I'm going to go
in and you've you've earned the
credibility and grew your million
probably two million now but you grew
your million uh subscribers based on the
work you've done and and the credit
you've got with your audience M I think
that's the right message to send now
listen if if a family member can get you
the Head Start you know D's gone on for
years you know your uncle or dad get you
to start in the family business or you
inherit the family business I mean you
should I want I want my kids to have a
head start don't you want your kids of
course but I'm saying like that happens
we're all aware that that happens you
know somebody knows somebody at a
university should we aspire to that like
you should be so great that your kids
will have a head start in life so so how
I see the world I believe everybody and
again this might be sound a bit mad I
believe everybody has Brilliance in them
in some form what that is it might be
stamp collecting that might be you know
football that might be basketball that
might be mathematics that might be art
that might be singing I don't know I I
believe everybody has a Brilliance that
has to be natured out of them if you get
a great parent or a great uh start in
life in terms of the card you dealt at
the start you know you get a great mom
and a great dad I think they n your
talents out some people have more
talents than one some people don't
believe they've got a a talent and and
put themselves down you know but I
believe your job as a person is to try
and encourage other people's skills out
of them now there's lots of people out
there saying I'm brilliant at this I'm
brilliant at that they're not the people
who it's people who are quietly
reluctant about their own greatness and
with greatness comes enormous
responsibility so it means you got to
have to be disciplined it means you're
going to have to work hard it means
you're going to have to be consistent it
means you're going to have to do things
that are tough you're not just going to
if if you've if you've been on a journey
of a hero's journey of making yourself
something in the world you'll realize
nine days out the 10 is a slug for the
one day you get at a cup final everybody
thinks a top player I only had probably
five Good Seasons out
of 12 13 14 15 I didn't have a good game
every week you know those spells where
you're injured and and you have to put
the the the tough and if we don't
explain to people how tough it is to be
elite and we say you just get there
based on um you know a box that needs to
be to be ticked then we're sending the
wrong message I want to get out there
and educate myself I want to get out
there and shine a light on great
messages like yours which is an
empowering message to to pull people up
um and people don't like the truth you
know in face Facebook Twitter went on
and put the note next to me orell quote
but I think it's an incredible quote
Orwell and and I'm reading a lot of them
lately when he says in times of
universal deceit telling the truth will
be seen as a revolutionary react and and
what he meant by Universal deceit was
somebody pontificating saying you should
do this this and this because this is
the right thing to do and then when
they're not when they're there they're
doing the complete opposite they're
telling you how to live your life how
you should behave what you should do and
they're doing the exact opposite to for
for negative purposes here and I do feel
when I turn on the TV and and the radio
in my
industry I've got people who are living
universally
deceitful lives trying to pontificate
and tell everybody else just how perfect
they are and just what they should be
doing nobody's perfect everybody's
capable of Brilliance and we should
encourage that out of them but to get
that Brilliance I believe unless you're
genius you've got to work hard for a
long time to Bear the fruit of of your
talent if you're a genius stuff might
happen quicker for you if your dad's a
genius or in a position of power and
influence or your mom is then you might
get a little bit of a Head Start like
Charlie Woods is going to get a head
start in golf because his dad's Tiger
Woods you know can't be grud Charlie
Woods you know deon's kids Beyonce's
kids you know Jay-Z if they want to
produce music well who who's better
position than the m and Dad so as I said
to you I believe in life you get Del
cards that you're not even aware of so
you get a mom card and a dad card if
you're
lucky if you're lucky your mom might be
an eight of eight of spades and your dad
might be an eight of hearts two steady
consistent people that you can build and
hopefully leave your kids better cards
than what you ad de some people leave W
worse cards than the would dels some
people get a 27 off suit some people get
a pair of frees some people get a a king
and a queen some people get if you're
very very lucky A Pair of Aces your job
is to leave your kids a better hand than
what you would dealt the the hand you
dealt doesn't necessarily mean you're
going to be successful in the game of
cards in because the river Comes The
Flop comes the the the you know I'm not
a big poker player but three cards come
out what's that called the t is it or
something what's it called in
poker what's it called in po when when
you've got your cards and the three
cards the Flop and then you
get another card and then it's the river
right so as you go through life you use
your cards you try and upskill your
cards to play the game of life and if
you do really really well you upskill
your cards you Inn um your kids a better
opportunity right in life but that
doesn't mean they're going to be
successful they've got to keep using
their cards I know some rich kids that
squandered every the worst thing that
ever happens to you I mean Friedrich n
was a son of a very very wealthy and and
went the complete opposite way yeah um
again I don't want to get too far off
off toer and that's something I'm going
to do I'm going to go when we podcast
hopefully land Lords I done a year of
University because I I went from 16
because I was a talented player into
professional football yts and made me
debut 18 19
and I didn't get the chance to go to
university and I wasn't interested in at
school I'm a young boy I just want to be
on the football pitches and and the
quicker I could get in the Premier
League club or get an opportunity to
better so I wasn't thinking of f
education even though I had a reasonable
level of intelligence and I felt I could
have passed tests and uh revised and and
and got the grades if needed them but I
knew I'd never need them in the you know
in the in the places I was going you
didn't need University grades and then
my wife has got a degree um and she
would talk about the process you know
the the time saved to get that and how
much it meant to her and I'd always kind
of wanted to get into further education
just as a challenge to say I can do it
so when I was at QPR I got frustrated
with the work environment I didn't think
it was stimulating me physically
emotionally mentally and I was
complaining about it and black he was me
great mentor said well stop moaning
about it change your training regime so
when I supplemented me training regime
got my own coaches and change you after
you you you're you're away from football
thought so we ended up enrolling at
rampton University and started a
Philosophy degree which is a 30-year-old
professional footballer going into a
class of 18 19 20 21 year old students
of all different backgrounds and
discussing philosophy was they just
rolled up behind you and they so i' done
a full year i' done a full year got me
got all my papers in dissertation and
then I got sold yeah so I had to move
Club from London to the north of England
so I've got me credits banked and I
spoke to me lecturer ra you want to
bring on the podcast he's fascinating
guy philosophy guy um see Indian guy and
um I've said to him look I want to go
and finish that I've started I want to
go and finish it and I wanted to be the
best football manager in the world but I
realized the way they are and the way
the game is currently I don't want any
part of it so I have to say something to
change the landscape and if they cancel
me no problem I'm independently wealthy
I've got a four kids to bring up I've
got a family to see and I've got lots of
golf to play so like they're not going
to be able to do anything other than
like force me into an ear retirement
which is so I'm lucky in terms of I've
looked around and
gone I'm perfectly positioned to be able
to speak on so many things in this
country that is like unbelievable just
because of my life experience what's
actually happened to me
um and I I honestly think what I've said
in the last week has compromised my
future employment in the game mhm but I
don't want any part of it if it Carries
On down this path I'd rather time out
step back from it than sell me soul to
stay in it and and I think football as I
say allows us hopefully to talk about
bigger societal issues because if we
don't work hard here and have serious
conversations and be prepared not to
agree doesn't mean you have to cancel
someone if they don't agree with you
it's important that we think uh together
but we don't think a life we won't get
anywhere we just get we we get more
regressive more um of the stuff we don't
want to see in society will come to the
four if we keep doing the stuff we're
doing like this
tokenistic um sweep across everything we
know is for me out of
control and dangerous well were your
thoughts when you got on Pierce did you
expect the interview you know me and
Pierce have had a bit of back and forth
so I
always there was a program on um I grow
I grew up and there was a program called
Harry Enfield and Chums which was comedy
and he he did a sketch on there about
the Scout hey calm down calm down you
like kayy wigs on but he do lots of the
other ones and there was a character in
there called Tim nice but him it was
very POS robot he didn't have a clue
what he was doing so every time so I met
Pier out um kind the first time I ever
met him and he is is a great guy
not a successful footballer but but
well-known personality um and he's like
hi so he thought I instantly recognized
him I was in company as a younger player
and he thought I recognized him I was
like I know you he's like so he thought
I recognized him off the team I played
along yeah know yeah you're really
famous you didn't want to tell me his
name I I know who you are I've got it
you're Tim nice but Di aren't you I've
har mfield like so he like he thought
was going to say y p Morgan obviously
I've done him and one started laughing
and it broke the ice and since then I've
always saved him in my phone as Tim nice
but him and he calls me the pit so he's
got me saved his phone is the pit so
after the exchange over day I'm like
surely you know now I'm the sheep dog
I've got like gray hairs in here me me P
Persona of playing is has gone um so so
that's where me and T where P's got on
WE we've disagreed on lots of things you
know there's lots of things he said and
done that I don't want to start a um
debate with pi that I don't agree with
lots of things lots of things both I
face be the same with me but I respect
his opinion sometimes he he gets really
emotional and and passionate about
topics that I've got no interest in but
I think my God he's really passionate at
least he cares at least he's trying to
do something no you just said today that
you didn't know we were coming on didn't
know we were coming on I that we were
going so luckily we've recorded it cuz I
got told P said I asked the producer he
says yeah you're going to come on P's
going to ask youed me before said you're
going to come on P is going to ask you
some questions and then and then that'll
be it might be 15 minutes yeah yeah no
problem so go on and then he sneaks on
there's going to be three people I'm
like who are these who is this so I'm
expect guys he thought I was going to
finish him so yeah it did so it comes on
and it's um and it's it's obviously uh
Bianca with with um her head opinion I
can't remember the other lady's name but
she was Bianca's tag teammate it was
like a it was like a poor karaoke poor
karaoke duet so they've give it to me
tight so I'm like okay I don't you know
I'm going to defend me position cuz I'm
not going to back down here well let's
hear what they got to say and then I'm
exp now they go now they go to you and
I'm like okay I don't know this lady but
you must be for them to save the best of
the last you must be coming now I'm
getting I'm getting the flamethrower off
here this is game set and match for the
for the feminist and you came on and we
on my team and I was like oh my God just
like a like thank thank you for for for
listening like if I could have hug you
i' reached out and hug you but if I'd
have been in the studio I think Bianca
would have Cho me bollocks off way
before we had the opportunity no if we
were in studio it would have been so
much better cuz the Bianca's mic was
above mine and and like I felt like hers
was like higher if we were all in studio
was the anger in a voice you know I
don't know I feel like if we were in
studio I could have got but again I I
mean I honestly I I don't think
she'd I don't think she'd be able to to
debate in Studio I think if she's
talking a piece to Cameron and she's
she's had somebody say this is what you
need to say this out when she put the
statement out the next day about what
you meant to say someone's obviously oh
she's written it or edited it with it on
on a Twitter and then I seen her
attacking you saying oh look at me or
whatever and it just reminded me it
reminded me of the school
playground no she came for me first
that's this thing she came for she came
for me she called me a Pik me so I said
okay okay so I just went through
Instagram to see see if there's a reason
she wasn't taken professionally no cuz
she she starts attacking me and on the
show she said she was passed over like
like she was like she said something
along the lines that she deserved more
opportunity than she got so I just I'm
an investigative Journal you know I just
I do my research and you as as I said to
you on there though if you dug a little
deeper well you a little deeper you that
was just bass that was just her
Instagram and then I'm the bad guy I'm
like all I did was Google what you put
out there like but again I think it's
revolutionary cuz sometimes when a man
says it tells the truth to a woman they
don't want to hear it all right but I
think when another woman says it I think
even if they don't want to hear it
they've got to take notice now we also
have to be mindful of I I believe in
radical truth but also deep down if I'm
honest none of us really want that so
for instance my wife's beautiful woman
in fantastic shape but if she ever said
to me how do I look in
this and I thought she looked at showa
I'd say I wouldn't wear that of you now
she's NE she never consults me cuz she's
really glamorous but if she did or her
ass look big and I would I would would
to say that I'd try and say it in a way
that didn't that you know that didn't
offend her and on the flip side of that
you know you know if I was to ask a
woman a question you know like cassus
cover your ears cover your ears like you
know men sometimes for for whatever
reason you know you've heard the stories
of men might be in the in the in a
moments and am I the best you've ever
had oh yeah well I'm like what are they
going to say no they pot inclin like you
can't turn around and say no like when
you're mid when you're mid session you
know but actually it actually pale
actually if she turn around and went no
no no you're like 15th like would you
want to hear that also so do we also
want to hear the truth no we don't but
also when it's stuff that does affect
society for the negative I think I think
we have to call it out so if there was a
hole in the sky was the famous Leonardo
DiCaprio movie that is it where there's
like a hole in the sky and no one's
talking about it is it what's it don't
look up like that's I'm I'm we're in
we're in we're in we're in that
territory of can we not say this we
don't say this this is like going to
crash into the Earth and cause a
catastrophic event this is leading to a
rising women facing a barage of online
abuse that they don't need to because
they shouldn't be in a position to even
say what they need to say to make
themselves a target for this and it's
rise you know if we do this if we carry
on down a tokenistic approach it's going
to lead to a rise in racism as well
which is what we don't want we want to
be more inclusive and build bridges yeah
and if we try to be too woke too soon
without thinking about it we're going to
cause absolute Carnage and we're already
seeing that I mean your country is fair
that Advance down the rabbit hole than
us but we are heading down it rapidly
yeah yeah well you know and that's why
it bothers me because I'm like when you
walk into a room you want people to know
that you deserve to be there rather than
you're just giving a hand out because
you're a pretty chick so how did you end
up taking this cause on how did what
what was the thing that broke the the
dam for you well everything kind of
started um I wanted to know why men
didn't want to get married okay um young
men just don't really want to get
married I kept hearing how bad it was so
I started doing a documentary on um
divorce in family court and that led me
to like why it is so hard for men to get
access to their children why are men
discriminated against for jobs and it
led me to women shouldn't vote because
that was the beginning of all of it I'm
going have to get one of these t-shirts
I'm oh we can we get your whole te we
have a bunch over you see me with that
on though SE me with that on I'm dead
I'm dead l get you all okay U well thank
you for coming on great to meet you P
where where can they find you have a new
podcast yeah we we haven't um we haven't
fully put the um like the Brandon and
all that together but it's going to
called common sense with Joey Bart it's
going to be cool people are going to
attack that cuz like you've got none so
how you how dare you talk about it um so
we're going to we're going to launch I
think February the 1 we're going to put
our first podcast out but we're building
bit of the infrastructure now as I say
to see your setup here this is like like
the death start isn't it this is like
news cor um compared to our like
basement setup so we we need to uh we
need to take some pointers off you but
like this is um this is how blings the
man the myth the legend with set
building yeah the man oh what look at
this
so thank you Christ I can imagine thank
you listen this will take pride of place
I might I might I might if I wear this
honestly if I wear this I almost wore
that on pier I thought about
wearing if I if I had have worn that I
think that one of these days I'm going
to wear it I'm so maybe if any if any of
the female footballers are brave enough
to come on and debate me I am going to
wear this t-shirt when I debate them
okay you have my we guys I can moderate
I'll do like a timer or something if you
if you um if you keep doing what you're
doing um you're sending a fantastic
message pill so honestly it's empowering
it's it's inspirational I was inspired
by by listening to you so keep up the
good fight and as I say great to meet
you and we'll be friends for life very
nice to meet you thank you guys for
watching um make sure you go follow what
are you going to be on YouTube yeah
we're going to go on YouTube obviously
my Twitter handle the common sense
podcast will spawn out there so we'll
start putting some clips on there
probably in the next you know little
short clips of of the stuff we've been
doing the last few weeks in the next
probably month and then we're launching
face the Feb and hopefully we can
disrupt the
marketplace and women shouldn't
vote guys every show I'm just going to
try to convince
whoever's he's thinking about I want to
do further research but every day is a
school day I didn't know about the
suffrage yet so I'll do Fair the yeah
they're crazy ladies guys like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
we'll talk to you next
time
[Music]